hallo leute wir sind wieder das easy
damenteam heute aus malibu ist es unser
letzter abend in den usa und wir haben
jetzt einige fragen für euch allerdings
fehlen mir die fragen denn die sind auf
bands handy und ben
der ist da wenn du bist wieder da wie
war es eigentlich gar nicht so klappt
wie erwartet und der vorne gibt es viele
steine sie tun müssen aber dann später
gibt's nur sand und ja wenn wir brauchen
fragen
von einem handy ach so ja nur wie sieht
es bei dir aus was machst du denn hier
am strand
ich gieße den ich genieße den showdown
in malibu und es ist sehr ruhig und sehr
gemütlich und sehr hübsch und sehe ja
ich dachte gerade auf deutsch heißt das
ja baywatch die rettungsschwimmer von
malibu und ich dachte ja geil jetzt sind
wir in malibu hier wurde ihnen eine
party hier wurde baywatch gedreht aber
dann hab ich nach obwohl es gedreht
wurde und das wurde gar nicht hier
gedreht wenn hast du fragen für uns die
erste freude von euch hallo leute
was denkt ihr über die afd alternative
für deutschland übrigens habe ich euch
liebe komm bitte nach brasilien
es ist von andrés ada adresse adresse an
dresser wir würden gerne brasilien
kommen sie ist auch die sie was hältst
du von der af de hallo auf die aktuelle
frage dass wir noch nicht hier am strand
wo meine sonnenuntergang so die aktuelle
frage ist was hältst du von der afd
eine eine bewegung die die an sich
berechtigt war am anfang und später
durch dumme menschen kompromittiert
wurde bis zu einem war maßstab dass es
nicht mehr tragbar ist und nicht mehr
haltbar
nichtsdestotrotz denke ich dass die
deutsche regierung und die deutschen
intellektuellen auch die einfachen
menschen besser deutlicher beruhigen
sollten also dass die angst aufgekommen
ist nachdem eine million flüchtlinge
nach deutschland gekommen ist und
zusammen mit grün zum unter einen
zusammenbruch der der gültigen
rechtlichen lage das kann man doch
nachvollziehen aber man muss das
erklären können
und wenn nicht dann kommen die dummen
menschen und machen ihre
verschwörungstheorien
es ist glaub ich denke ich dass die
dummen menschen sowieso kommen und man
kann das nicht ganz verhindern
und ja wie ich schon sagte also adresse
hat gefragt nach der afg und also meine
erklärung oder was viele nicht wissen
ist die fd wurde früher mal am anfang
als euro kritische partei gegründet das
heißt die leute hatten vor allem
wirtschaftliche aspekte die das
gegründet haben
und die wollten gerne das deutschen aus
der eurozone austritt und mittlerweile
ist die partei quasi gehackt worden von
ja vor allem rassistischen leuten die
eigentlich nur programm machen mit angst
vor fremden und angst vor muslimen und
das ist sehr schade weil die kfd war
jetzt vorher auch nicht nur tolle partei
aus meiner sicht aber jetzt ist eine
rechte partei und das brauchen wir
eigentlich in deutschland nicht aber
trotzdem muss man sich damit
auseinandersetzen
die partei ist heute ja man sieht vor
allem islamkritische und islamfeindliche
positionen und die gründer der partei
die die partei gegründet
sind heute nicht mehr in der afg und
sagen mittlerweile in talkshows wir
haben ein monster geschaffen
also man kann sich das ungefähr so
vorstellen ist es so populistisch wie
donald trump leider
okay wir müssen vom strand runter kommen
wir machen noch mal einen eine umrundung
zusammen kommt jetzt drauf gut dann
müssen wir runter vom strand und leider
wir fahren weiter und wir sehen uns
gleich aus dem auto wir sind jetzt auf
der straße sind vom strand
rausgeschmissen
wenn name noch eine frage haben wir von
zig bastelsets glaub du bist engländer
weil ich schreibe hier made in halo zu
intelligenz vor dem haus ins exil ging
das ganze ins gremium origins ja die
frage habe ich ausgesucht weil das genau
der grund ist warum wir es schaffen
nämlich er kennt deutschland sich damit
aus leute zu integrieren und deutschland
ist in den letzten 40 jahren 50 jahren
zu einem einwanderungsland geworden und
zu einem multikulturellen land geworden
und das ist genau der grund warum wir
nämlich keine angst vor immigranten
haben und das ist eigentlich ein guter
grund und in deiner in einer frage wird
übrigens zwei fehler
erstens stimmt es nicht dass wir es
nicht geschafft haben die türken zu
integrieren sondern töten sind
eigentlich ein fester bestandteil
unserer gesellschaft vom nach berlin und
prüfe das selbst ja wir haben in berlin
keine ahnung wie viele millionen türken
und essen freunde also du hast vier
millionen konflikte mit den die
deutschen und die türken
ob sie sich jetzt mehr oder weniger ein
bisschen abkapseln und integrieren
ich kann zu negativ beispiel finden aber
ein großteil der türken lebt ganz normal
zusammen zum deutschen wie sind deutsche
das ist ja der ist wir haben türkische
freundin der türkischen nachbarn wir
essen gerne bei türen also türken sind
ein teil den wir gar nicht missen
möchten unserer gesellschaft und der
zweite fehler ist es sind nicht drei
millionen immigranten letztes jahr nach
deutschland gekommen sondern es waren
900.000 und wir haben keine angst davor
das zu schaffen oder nein gar keine
angst weil was er nicht wie ihr habt
eine entfernung davor dass ihr mit eurer
eigenen räder fantasieren lebt in
wirklichkeit wenn du in berlin nehmen
würdest würdest du die flüchtlinge auch
sehen und ich würde es verstehen dass
sie sich wirklich freuen der dem krieg
entkommen zu sein und hier ein normales
leben unter halbwegs normales leben
führen zu dürfen auf jeden fall ein
leben mit einer hoffnung auf besseres
was dann kommt und nur ein kleines
prozent der kriminellen die überall in
allen schichten da ist klar mit denen
werden wir probleme bekommen und die
werden uns vielleicht auch irgendwann
verletzten aber auch damit müssen wir
fertig werden ja also sieg passt du bist
eingeladen nach berlin er wird nur wenn
du nicht mehr so lustig bis trend war
das eine gute antwort sehr gut
diese frage noch besser und jannis
komplette ins bild diese frage ist von
und er oder sie schreibt es ist ein
bisschen lustig für mich wie janosch ein
hemd über ein anderes hemd trägt versteh
mich nicht falsch ist super
also erstens so viel equipment mitnehmen
müssen dass sich extrem wenig kaputten
mitgenommen haben deshalb sieht er mich
immer ständig in den gleichen traum
noten zweitens ich haben ähnliche weise
meine jacke bei der schule in manitou
springs liegen lassen vergessen ist
laufe ich ohne jacke und wir haben zu
wenig zeit um mir eine neue werke zu
kaufen
genau und pullover mach dich nicht so
behandelte ich diesen dieses hemd jetzt
als meine jacke zeigt mir bitte
wir finden das auch witzig also ist
nicht der einzige dem das auftreten froh
dass es nicht regnet ja
heute hat in die hose gemacht denn was
ist denn da passiert sollte nicht sagen
was ist das hier wenn hast du deine hast
du deine hosen ähnlichen abdruck easy
und wenn wollten unbedingt francisco
also haben eric und sarah sie zu einem
klub gebracht es war glaube ich einst
ungefähr finden nach 1 dann gab es in
dem club 25 dollar eintritt also haben
sie 50 dollar bezahlung in den club zu
gehen und dort partys zu machen und dann
haben sie einen drink gehabt ist lief
techno musik und was passiert dann
um 2 uhr worten aus dem nächsten trinken
und sagt uns alle so nah hin hier könnt
ihr kein dünger bekommen um 2 uhr ist
chicago märz besser als wir gehen jede
bahn versuchen das nein man kann kein
alkohol kommen
die dummen deutschen wir die einzigen
die nicht wussten dass es ab 2 und keine
freundin carol mit undenkbar in
deutschland undenkbar also wenn es in
deutschland nachts kein alkohol mehr
geben würde
was wären da los sie verlor ihn sucht
das haben sie uns mit cisco gesagt das
war schockierend sagt mir wir haben aber
heroin
also dann da saßen wir doch nie war die
fahne wieder zurück nach deutschland und
saufen noch mehr den namen noch eine
frage
gibst du maria riesch ließ uns noch eine
frage vor marina bay
kommt mal nach russland oder nach
russland
berlin möchte sehr gerne nach russland
oder weißrussland kommen
wir möchten einen spielball hilfen denn
nach dieser tollen reiseerfahrung wo wir
jetzt vier wochen durch die usa gefunden
mit dem sie gerne team möchten wir
überall hinfahren und janisch hat
erstmals ja ich mag eigentlich reisen
nicht gerne mag in seinem zimmer sitzen
und gitarre spielen und jannis hat jetzt
zum ersten mal auf dieser erfahrung wo
wir so viele tolle menschen
kennengelernt haben die easyjet gucken
schulen universitäten menschen privat zu
hause die uns eingeladen haben das
persönliche erfahrung dass wir gerne
eine easy german world tour also eine
weltreise machen möchten dass es unser
großer plan für 2017 und wir haben wir
schreiben uns viele leute die sagen
kommt mal dahinter mal dahin ich möchte
euch einladen damit wir das ein bisschen
besser sortieren können haben wir ein
formular auf gemacht
auf unserer website und ich poste den
link hier unten in den kommentaren und
über dieses formular könnt ihr uns
einladen das kind ist schreiben
wir sind eine schule oder ich bin
deutschlehrer ich möchte euch in meine
klasse 1
oder ich möchte euch einfach privat
treffen oder ich möchte euch gerne
einladen bei mir zu übernachten was
immer ihr machen möchtet könnt ihr ein
schreiben und dann werden wir gucken
dass wir euch irgendwie besuchen also
früher oder später klappt das auch in
weißrussland und russland auf mechanisch
möchtest du gerne meine russland eine
russische seele sehnt sich nach der
weite des russischen landes jannis
trinkst du gerade heimlich alkohol auf
der straße in amerika ja russische weise
das kannst uns bitte noch eine frage
vorlesen
also das ist eine frage von jacob den
können wir aus berlin jacob hat uns
schon öfters getroffen und er sagt
eigentlich manche habt ihr eigentlich
manche amis interviews zum beispiel was
sie denken über deutschland und dann
kannst das ende der vorherigen jacob hat
gesagt er macht immer ein spiel und
fragt leute nach assoziationen zum
beispiel pizza italien oder donald
amerika und dann sagt er immer deutsch
man sagt der deutschland und den meisten
leute sagen nazis hat er uns geschrieben
und wir sollen das spiel selber spielen
haben wir leider noch nicht geschafft
aber sehr gute idee und am ende schreibt
er
rps ich bin seit heute petschel danke
baker und pps ich freue mich auf den
nächsten stammtisch im prater prima der
nächste stammtisch ist im november an
schaut bitte auf unsere facebook seite
und dort findet ihr
die adresse und den termin wir freuen
uns wenn ihr uns trifft in berlin und
pps wie sagt oder schreibt man ps auf
deutsch
gs schreibt man auf deutsch genauso wie
im englischen ist das nicht toll wenn
wusstest du das eigentlich nicht nehmen
und du bist ja der offizielle easy
german übersetzer aber wie ich abhängig
würde ich jetzt sagen everyday school
nbs
kreativ ps das stimmt wenn dein gesicht
ganz komisch aus wenn es von unten
beleuchtet ist
letzte frage wann kommt er nach italien
diese frage ist von libri.de veronika
veronika oder libri libri.de veronika
wir kommen genau dann nach italien wie
gerade schon gesagt füllt unser formular
aus guckt führte ihn in die kommentare
wenn ihr irgendwo wohnt in der welt und
habe lust uns mal zu treffen oder uns
einzuladen
egal ob in eure schule nach hause in
euro uni oder wo immerhin dann schreibt
uns bitte wir freuen uns und wir möchten
irgendwann um die welt reisen mit easy
german danke bis hierhin vielen vielen
dank fürs zuschauen
danke nochmal an alle die uns auf
unserer usa unterstützt haben wir hatten
die geister zeit überhaupt wie war die
usa in einem wort zusammengefasst
nein
überraschen
und ben
vielfältig oder so will ich sagen aber
so vielfältig ist gut und ich sage es
war einzigartig hier hinten sieht ihr
unser autor ist gemietet haben mit dem
sind wir gerade vier wochen durch die
gegend gefahren
morgen gehen wir es ab und fliegen ab
nach deutschland das wird sehr traurig
denn in deutschland sind es ungefähr 0
grad herz und es ist ein bisschen kühler
danke dass ihr uns an unterstützt und
dank an alle die uns diese wunderbare
zeit ermöglicht haben und uns hier
willkommen geheißen haben danke danke
dank
glaub mir zu sprechen
und
eine notwendig